Joe Biden gave a speech today on this j6
eve where he said I kid you not that we
almost lost this country over January 6
and my response immediate was like wow
if a thousand dudes who are unarmed
riding at a government building is
enough to destroy this nation we're
going to have to cancel all of our
Foreign Wars and foreign funding because
we are we are much too weak to be
involved in any kind of War if a
thousand unarmed dudes riding at the
capital is going to destroy the fabric
of this nation of course Joe Biden's
full of it and it's not true but this is
his his play I guess January 6th is
tomorrow it's the anniversary and uh
this is his big uh his his his pitch to
the American people as to why we should
vote for him again I guess you know I
got I got to say it's actually quite
remarkable because I remember all the
other campaigns where they'd say
something like John McCain is bad on
taxes and bad on America and it's like
taxes that was the issue